[Music]  well that was fast the untitled Han Solo  movie already has its new director we  learned Phil Lord and Chris Miller were  fired from the Star Wars standalone  movie Lucasfilm announced Thursday  morning oscar-winning director Ron  Howard is officially taking over it was  only Tuesday we learned of Lord Miller's  firing both parties released a statement  citing creative differences Lord and  Miller saying quote unfortunately our  vision and process weren't aligned with  our partners on this project but  creative differences aside this movie  remains scheduled for its May 2018  release date and will pick back up  filming on July 10th this time with Ron  Howard at the helm  so are you still excited for the Han  Solo movie are you on board with Ron  Howard being behind the camera let us  know in the comments below or of course  you can shout with me over on Twitter  [Music]  you